♪ ♪
>> Laura: WE ALL KNOW ABOUT
AMERICA'S RISING CRIME RATES,
ESPECIALLY VIOLENT DOMINIC
VIOLENT CRIME IN URBAN AREAS.
BUT TO DO KNOW INCREASING NUMBER
BEING COMMITTED BY YOUNG TEENS?
MATT FINN IS IN LOS ANGELES TO
TELL US MORE.
>> OVER THE PAST FEW DAYS,
EXTREMELY DISTURBING CRIMES
COMMITTED BY TEENS IN CHICAGO.
THREE BOYS 14 AND UNDER WERE
CHARGED WITH FELONY --
AGGRAVATED CARJACKING.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA, HORRIFYING
ROBBERY VIDEO.
HIS HAMMER SYSTEM UNDER, A
CHINATOWN CAMERA STORE, THREE
TEENS USED A HAMMER TRYING TO
SMASH THE GLASS CASES BUT THEY
ARE PLEXIGLAS AND DO NOT CRACK.
A CO-OWNER GRABS A BAT AND
STARTS SWINGING.
NEIGHBORING WORKERS RUSHED INTO.
THE CO-OWNER SAID HE GOT PEPPER
SPRAY, HIT IN THE HEAD WITH A
HAMMER, NEEDING TEN STITCHES.
AND IN NEW ORLEANS, A
73-YEAR-OLD GRANDMOTHER WAS
KILLED AFTER HER ARM WAS RIPPED
OFF DURING A CARJACKING.
VIDEO APPEARS TO SHOW THE WOMAN
INNOCENTLY IN HER OWN CAR WHEN A
GROUP OF TEENS RUSHED AND THEN
CARJACKED HER.
NEIGHBORS AND WITNESSES WERE
SCREAMING AND TRIED TO
INTERVENE.
HER ARM GOT CAUGHT IN THE
SEAT BELT AND WAS SEVERED AS THE
FOUR TEENS DROVE HER CAR AWAY,
DRAGGING HER FOR ONE BLOCK.
THE STOLEN CAR WAS RECOVERED
ABOUT 13 BLOCKS AWAY.
>> I CAN'T SAY THIS ENOUGH.
WHEN THEY PULLED AWAY AND SHE
WAS IN THAT STRAP, THEY MADE THE
DECISION TO MURDER, THEY SHOULD
PAY FOR IT.
>> NEW ORLEANS POLICE ARRESTED
FOUR MINERS FOR THAT DEADLY
CARJACKING.
THE POLICE SUPERINTENDENT WANTS
THEM CHARGED AS ADULTS.
LAURA.
>> Laura: MATT, THAT IS SO
UPSETTING ON SONY LEVELS.
THANK YOU.
>> IT IS.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
JOHN MacARTHUR, GRACE
COMMUNITY CHURCH PASTOR.
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU TONIGHT.
I IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT OF YOU
BECAUSE I WANTED TO ASK YOU WHAT
YOU THOUGHT WAS AT THE HEART OF
THIS, THESE INTERCITY YOUTHS,
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS
AMERICA.
HOW DID THINGS GET THIS BAD?
>> WELL, I THINK YOU KNOW,
LAURA, THAT HUMANITY IS CAPABLE
OF SOME HORRENDOUS CRIMES,
WHETHER IT'S KILLING A SENIOR
CITIZEN OR BOMBING HOSPITAL FULL
OF CHILDREN IN THE UKRAINE, AND
GOD HAS BUILT INTO SOCIETY SOME
RESTRAINTS.
THE FIRST RESTRAINT IS THE
KNOWLEDGE OF GOD, THAT THERE IS
A RIGHTEOUS AND HOLY JUDGE TO
WHOM WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT IS A RESTRAINT ON EVIL.
BEYOND THAT, THERE IS THE LAW OF
GOD WRITTEN IN THE HEART, EVERY
CULTURE KNOWS WHAT IS RIGHT AND
WRONG.
THE UNIVERSE, PART OF BEING IN
GOD'S IMAGE.
THERE IS THE CONSCIENCE.
WE HAVE A SOCIETY BASICALLY THAT
HAS REMOVED GOD SO THAT
TRANSCENDENTAL RESTRAINT IS GONE
THAT HAS FLIPPED MORALITY ON ITS
HEAD, SO CONSCIENCE IS
MISINFORMED.
THE NEXT RESTRAINT IS THE
FAMILY.
DESTROY THE FAMILY AND THERE'S
NO OPPORTUNITY FOR DISCIPLINED
RAISING OF CHILDREN TO MAKE THEM
SOCIALLY CAPABLE OF INTERACTING
IN A POSITIVE WAY.
THE FAMILY FALLS APART AND THE
NEXT BARRIER IS THE POLICE, AND
BY THEN, IT'S BEYOND THEM.
I MEAN, WITNESS THE RIOTS LAST
SUMMER WHEN THE POLICE JUST
STAND THERE AND WATCH.
IT'S A SEQUENCE OF THINGS WHERE
THIS SOCIETY, THE YOUNG IN THE
SOCIETY, HAVE SMASHED EVERY
DIVINE RESTRAINT DOWN AND IT
OVERWHELMS THE FINAL
GOVERNMENTAL INSTITUTION, WHICH
IS THE POLICE, AND THEN YOU CAN
ADD -- THROW IN HOW MUCH
LAWLESSNESS THERE IS AT EVERY
LEVEL, WHETHER IT'S EVEN
POLITICIANS OR THE IMMORALITY OF
HEROES, ATHLETES, MOVIE ACTORS,
THE CULTURE IS SO IMMORAL, SO
AGAINST THE FAMILY, SO AGAINST
GOD, AND YOU SO THAT AND YOU
REAP EXACTLY WHAT WE GET TODAY.
>> Laura: PASTOR MacARTHUR,
I THINK PEOPLE JUST WAKE UP AND
I THINK OUT OF THIS HAPPEN, BUT
YOU JUST LAID IT OUT BEAUTIFULLY
IN ALL OF THESE SAD, DISTURBING
WAYS THAT THIS HAPPENS OVER TIME
AND EVERY INSTITUTION WHICH ACTS
AS A CHECK ON THE INDIVIDUAL IS
UNDER ATTACK OR CAST ASIDE AND
WE HAVE THE RESULTS AROUND US.
I KNEW YOU WOULD SAY THIS SO